like salesforce build the platform and
put everything uh businesses need
we are gonna build the platform around
the instant messaging channels and put
everything that businesses need so this
is the next generation of customer
engagement
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with lumitec sponsored by
homeward ventures hippo insurance oppos
labs synergy global hillel at stanford
leap birthright excel serona partners
and in media partnership with c-tech
get ready for a very special episode of
20 minute leaders with yanir khalissar
the ceo and co-founder of wattsley he
has more than 12 years of
entrepreneurship background and vast
experience in the management and
development of b2b sas solutions in 2009
yanio became the first employee of an
israeli startup called insitera which
was acquired by mariquetto the leading
marketing automation solution in 2013.
he later founded kalistar solutions ltd
a marketing solutions company that aimed
to solve marketing teams tech pain
points by building integrative tools
that help them automate their business
and marketing operations
yanir khalasar welcome to 20 minute
leaders i'm so honored to have you here
thank you for being here
yeah thanks michelle for inviting me uh
it's great uh being here today
we're gonna have a great time um you
know i'm so curious about startups and
about startup journeys and there's a lot
of media around there's a lot of news
and hype in today's world and it's and
i'm so excited when i meet somebody
who's developed something that actually
creates value and how do we know that it
creates value because you've
bootstrapped this company for so long
and creating actual product market fit
with limited resources proven what your
product is doing and and recently
announced the phenomenal 11 million
dollars seed around uh which is just to
say the validation of the hard work that
you've done led by the incredible zef
ventures by oren zev amongst an
incredible list of of investors one by
one top of their industries so so first
of all janier you know huge
congratulations on on the journey so far
and thank you for coming here to share
it with me
uh thanks i think uh the journey was
very exciting so far and um and the
future is very bright so we'll actually
disrupting uh or actually we do not
disrupt
an industry we actually build a new
category that does not exist so this is
kind of very very it's fascinating uh to
be a part of this kind of a journey um
and uh yeah and i think that nowadays uh
when we hear about many companies going
ipo and you know we were all there when
they just started and they were
operating as early-stage startups
and seeing them growing uh that much and
becoming unicorns this is very very
exciting and it's great to be part of
this ecosystem i love it in here you
know you're talking about defending a
new category what is this new category
that you're defining here
yeah so i was uh actually uh you
mentioned our uh
fund fundraise that we just closed in
november last year just two and a half
months ago and i think that um
during the the process of raising the
fund so it was very very interesting
because until this point of time we were
running bootstrap so as a bootstrap
company for uh two and a half years uh
you know it's just uh
handling whatever you have on the way
and just focusing on doing sales and
developing the best product uh you can
and then at the point of time when you
say okay uh we are going to raise funds
so
suddenly you start like thinking about
the messaging and thinking about uh you
know the bigger picture and how like
what next you're gonna build right so
this is a very interesting process and
then it uh really helped us to uh
understand and to see the bigger picture
and to understand that what we're
building building here is not just a few
millions of dollars a company this is a
potential to be a billion a multi
multi-billion dollar company uh and the
fact that we are building a category so
let me just briefly tell about what
we're doing so today we have a platform
that connects what's up in salesforce so
we are the only ones in the world that
provide this kind of solution i mean
there are other uh solutions for
chatbots over whatsapp and then you can
integrate these uh chatbots with
salesforce in that way or another but we
are the only ones that covering the
one-on-one uh engagement sales people
have with customers directly from their
own personal or business whatsapp
so
if you think if it sounds to you like a
small plugin so um it might it's kind of
true right because this is how we
started it was supposed to be a small
plugin a small connector uh so two and a
half years ago when i thought about this
idea uh it came from a challenge that i
i had back then like i was talking with
customers a lot over whatsapp and then i
said there must be a tool or some
solution that i can use in order to be
more productive and you know to know the
history of all the customers that i'm
chatting with so this was the pain point
that i was trying to solve so i started
the company by myself i was one-man show
for almost a year
and then i came up with this plugin yeah
so i came up with this plugin and it
took me like a few weeks to develop it
like just the poc right just the basic
product but then very quickly i started
closing more customers and more
customers and not just like the first
customer was from israel i didn't know
this company uh a ski deal so i i'm not
um so much a big fan of uh doing ski i'm
a bit scared of it actually but um uh
they approached me and the sales force
administrator there he told me wow i was
looking for a solution like you provide
for two years
wow like there is a validation yeah so
and you know at the beginning it was
like more of small customers small
companies that were reaching out to me
and tell me and told me like you're
solving a very like a big pain point
that we are having sales people are not
uh productive enough and they cannot
focus on doing sales because they need
to do manual work all the time right
copy pasting the chat from what's up to
salesforce so this was kind of the poc
but then very very uh uh quickly i
started closing more and more deals and
in latin america and in europe and in
many many countries around the world
and slowly i started getting even
enterprise customers
uh asking about the product and starting
the process with them so
then slowly it became from a small
plugin from small connector to platform
and then um a year after i was running
by myself um
wait wait wait wait i have to to dwell
on this year by yourself
you know they say a lot that being a
founder and being a ceo is very lonely
at the top but there's no top here
there's a top middle and bottom and bo
all of them are you
wha what's the both the rationale of
running by yourself
in that moment and what was that like
um so i think this is uh uh
the answer to this question starts a few
years before so uh maybe it's good to to
tell to say a few words about myself so
in the past 13 years i'm in high tech so
i i started my career working for a
small israeli startup company called
insightera i actually joined the two
co-founders i was the first employee
that they hired
and then we developed a web
personalization platform
for b2b companies and we were like back
in 2009 we were the only ones that uh
that done that
and um we were growing very very fast
and we sold the product to many many big
companies around the world and three
years after we launched it marketo which
is a global marketing automation uh
market leader
they acquired us
and then uh being a part of marketo i
was a very interesting and very uh uh
insightful uh journey because i had a
very interesting position i was engaging
with some of the top the largest
customers of marketo had back then and i
was listening to their pain points their
technological pain points and i was the
person that actually delivers custom
solutions tailor-made solutions to help
them solve these uh pain points so that
led me to understand how big companies
think what pain points what challenges
they're trying to solve and how to uh
make transform these pain points into
micro solutions and then after marketo
got acquired in 2016 i transformed this
into my own business and i started
developing more and more micro solutions
mainly in the marketing sales and crm
integrations and i had more than 15
solutions like that that some of the top
companies in israel and in the us uh
were using so uh waxley was supposed to
be another plugin
at the beginning but then very like a
matter of few weeks i realized that
something much bigger than that is
happening and this is when i said okay i
need to be focusing on this
so i think that the experience the
background of how to build to take
something small like a pain point that
is very very uh big for companies and
then build a solution and also i think
i'm a big fan of um
working with customers getting the
feedback and implementing it into the
product now when you're a small startup
like small typical startup we're talking
about 10 people right so like getting
the feedback from customer and
implementing it and making a feature or
a module in the product might take a few
weeks few months if you're a bigger
company it takes years right or it never
happens but uh when you are a one-man
show so uh i got to a point where i'm
ending i'm i'm hanging up the call with
a customer and then 45 minutes later
there is a feature in the product
i think that uh yanir what you're
touching on here uh really amazingly it
sounds a lot like the shayed mentality
the navy seals of israel and
i i have a colleague now who was in the
shed and so i've come to understand this
mentality of a small cohort of people
that are so
decisive and they're so agile and but
they're also skilled enough to be able
to execute themselves and the the pace
at which you can run is just so much so
much faster and i think that that that
is something that you're going to leave
me pondering here right after the
episode as well but what i do want to
touch on i just i just want to share a
tip that i always give to uh i'm
advising to many small early stage
startups maybe in the first days they
run and my tip is always you know when
you have an idea so it's very easy and
you know all of us are very very uh
creative and innovative like to start
saying ah we can do that we can make it
look like that and also let's integrate
with that and i think that bottom line
if you just stop and you say okay let's
put all the ideas in one place but the
minimum like the mvp model i think this
is a great model uh to follow when you
are starting so just do the minimum you
can uh just to be able to deliver the
value the basic value that your
customers ask and need
and then whenever you have this poc
suddenly and today 99 of the product is
based on what we got from customers
right i just started basic stuff and
then everything uh came later along with
the customers
product like growth and in in the most
in the most real way possible and i
think one of the most you know
incredible things that you're doing here
is you're connecting two worlds that
have
two worlds that have emerged in the last
few years
that we that sort of grew
very distinctly apart we have one is
this instant messaging phenomena that
we're used to right that now everywhere
we go where we're instant messaging with
each other this is how we get things
done we expect customer service this way
because it's the most friendly way on
the other hand we expect businesses to
be to be had be more data driven to
collect more data points and use more
enterprise software like salesforce and
now the question stems how do you do
instant messaging experience while
allowing the business to have that
enterprise data driven mentality and you
touch exactly uh so you asked me about
the vision what what where where we are
going to um
you you touched exactly on the point i
think that
i had a call with um one of uh
one of the top vc's in israel
that really wanted to be a part of this
round of the recent round but
unfortunately uh they could like it
didn't uh work uh uh for this round but
hopefully they will be part of the next
round and then on the call um the
managing partner there she told me
you know you are disrupting the market
like salesforce done it uh 20 years ago
and i asked her what do you mean because
no one told me that uh before and she
told me look 20 years ago there were
many crm solutions in the world right
but then salesforce came and said you
know we're going to put our crm in the
cloud and it's not just the crm in the
cloud we will be that platform and we'll
put everything that businesses need in
order to support their first road uh
inside the crm so they want to need to
leave the crm the sales people will let
everything inside it and they disrupted
the market right and this is why they
are so successful 20 years later and i
think that as you said
today and especially post pandemic
everything is going to instant messaging
everything is being done over instant
messaging and i started saying before
that at the beginning like it was small
companies but then slowly i started
seeing more and more companies coming
from latin america asking about the
product and then i i started doing the
research and i understood why
specifically latin america so look in
israel we do everything over whatsapp
right
in latin america they do everything only
over whatsapp so they don't
they don't use emails they don't do face
to face because it's covered and if you
call your customer
you might lose the deal because it's
good to do it so volkswagen other
automotive companies subaru
they are using
whatsapp to sell cars
completely on whatsapp they are selling
cars over whatsapp and you know it took
me a while to to digest that but then
and then if you think about it they have
all the customer data inside the crm but
the missing part is what happens
throughout the journey right how what
led to the uh deal being closed
they don't have any visibility so they
use waxley today
to help their dealers uh sell more cars
and also to finally have the visibility
because the instant messaging are
blackbox is blackbox they don't have the
integration with the crm and with other
systems in the organization
so
uh like salesforce build the platform
and put everything businesses need
we are going to build the platform
around the instant messaging channels
and put everything that businesses need
so this is the next generation of
customer engagement
beautiful the name watsley how i get the
watts from whatsapp perhaps but what's
the lly
um there is not so much meaning so i was
awesome
i was identifying yeah uh it was the
first name that i had in mind when uh
you know we talked a minute ago about
moving fast like not stopping uh to
think too much like of course we've done
a lot of thinking all the way but you
know about the critical things and uh
yeah so far watley like played uh well
um uh with the product that we currently
have but as i said like now the vision
is to integrate with other instant
messaging channels with other crm
solutions
get to new industries and i think like
soon we're gonna we're gonna change it
we're gonna do a rebranding but uh yeah
this wasn't the priority
well i love watson so please consult
with me before you do a rebranding and
i'll kind of be sure if you get a phone
call i i'll what's up you when we're
changing ah there you go and i'll and
it'll go straight into my sales force
you know a lot of companies today
they don't like to be compared to others
they don't like to say oh you're like
google for that or or you're like
facebook for that
you're hugging the comparison you're
hugging the integration
that is watsly right a lot of startups
are fighting you know oh you're
integrating with that so you're just
doing that you're actually hugging it
and saying this is a core our core you
know existence
is there any resistance from that any
any thoughts about that or is it just
you know a natural thing for you the
fact that you're that your slogan is
saying we're connecting whatsapp and
salesforce so you know you have other
companies names in your slogan which is
quite unique in today's market where
founders often try to disengage with any
other company in their branding
so so i think um the logo and the
messaging so far was very very niche
right i was very specific i was very
tailored to uh the pain point or the
challenge that we help companies uh ask
for
uh as i said like now the next
generation the next phase the next uh um
um uh a part of our life life
the journey is to do the rebranding as
we are just
switching off from um uh just the
integration between what's up in
salesforce and we will be a platform
that helps
companies to improve customer experience
over instant messaging channels help
making their sales people much more
productive in their work
much more successful in closing deals
and
keeping this the systems of the com the
company updated and also for management
teams to have the visibility into these
customer interactions that today they're
completely blind about um i also wanted
to
mention one more use case
that we have with many of our customers
and this is kind of uh very uh scaling
up in the past few months
um
specifically when we're talking so
like the fact that customer facing
people are using instant messaging
channels it creates many many challenges
some of them what i mentioned before but
i think that there is a much larger
challenge or a risk
um you know when we're talking about
finance companies or healthcare
insurance even telecom
there is a huge risk of compliance right
there is a record-keeping regulation on
like every country
and these companies must document every
interaction that they have with
customers in any channel so if you go to
the bank over here
um
you meet your person over there or some
representative of the bank he will
document every word that he tells you
and also anything that you reply to him
also when you're calling them they
always tell you this call might be
monitored for uh training and uh
regulation
so
it's not happening today over what's up
and you know what is the interesting
part i don't know if you saw the news uh
last month um jp morgan chase got to 200
million dollars fine for not monitoring
for not documenting design interactions
over whatsapp so again this is a huge
pain point and um we closed we closed uh
we have a cast a few customers in the
financial industry already um a few very
uh huge uh financial advisory companies
in brazil in latin america
that are aware of this regulation and
they did know that they must solve it as
soon as possible so these are the more
large deals that we're closing these
days um
i do think that the story about latin
america is very interesting as well
so uh you know all
every generic uh every uh standard
israeli startup company when it starts
so it's they say like yeah we're gonna
build the product we're gonna build the
r d team over here in israel and then
business development in palo alto
and i think that many people don't know
the latin american market and i didn't
know it either right um
they're only in brazil which is the
largest economy in latin america
you want to guess how many medium size
and larger companies are there over
there you want to guess i love guessing
games
how many medium
small medium-sized businesses in brazil
and larger yeah
i would in brazil i would go for
maybe 50 000.
5 million
no yeah
so the economy over there is huge there
are 200 million oh my god there are 200
million people in brazil now live aside
the fact that this is the second largest
market for whatsapp around the world
this is why we're focusing there um
you know many companies
like and also 82 of the businesses use
whatsapp to engage with customers so
this makes a lot of sense for us to
focus in brazil
yanir i want to ask for a favor
i have about 50 more questions that i
have in my mind right now to ask you and
i call the show 20 minute leaders and i
have to abide by by the rule that i
unfortunately said but
i already want to book you for another
episode and i want to hear the story of
of breaking into the latin america
market
from somebody who didn't know it before
researched it came across it product led
growth validation came in inbound and
now is doing some incredible things
there
and so i want to book you for another
episode just on that and and ask the 50
questions i have in my mind but for now
i want to thank you for being here and
for sharing with me your journey this
was fascinating and i absolutely loved
it and and now i love watsley and it's
incredible and thank you very very much
in here thank you very much for inviting
me and looking forward for the next uh
for the next time
i'm excited thank you
[Music]